dernier portrait que nous diffusons ce
soir sur les têtes de liste aux
élections régionales celui de laurent
fabius dans une région quadrillée à
gauche au fil des élections
laurent fabius a toujours réalisé des
scores supérieurs à ceux du parti
socialiste au niveau national portrait
jean paul mousseau et stéphane vote
moi j'ai refusé tout ce qui est grand
tapage médiatique et je vais au contact
pour écouter les gens et leur proposer
un certain nombre de choses
la campagne de laurent fabius semaine au
pas de charge un ratissage systématique
aux quatre coins du département fut un
des grands glose politique
elles ne font plus recette le terrain
les inaugurations les remises de
médailles sont pour le candidat laurent
fabius le moyen idéal de réconcilier le
pays profond et le pays légal
boutique voit le jour là nous sommes à
peu aujourd'hui la cerise sur le gâteau
mais ça a demandé beaucoup beaucoup de
travail
deux réunions de
notre-dame-de-bondeville à blangy
sombrait le style ne change pas laurent
fabius tente de casser l'image plaqué
par ses adversaires d'homme d'appareil
froid est hors d'atteinte
il se veut le candidat du renouveau le
rempart contre le discrédit que
rencontrent les partis traditionnels en
général et le ps en particulier ou bien
on arrivera à voir une rénovation de nos
formations politiques ça que je
travaille
une rénovation des thèmes une rénovation
des personnes qui est très nécessaire
une relation l'organisation et dans ce
cas-là bon les gens diront ben voilà on
a besoin de formation publics ou bien
les formations politiques actuelles
n'arriveront pas se renouveler et à sont
là c'est à dire autre chose et moi un
match c'est au niveau en particulier de
la haute normandie
l'arrivée à une rénovation de ce
formation la nation besoin mot d'ordre
de fait campagne de charme l'emploi et
la formation la région et ses 105 mille
chômeurs manque de formation appliquée
laurent fabius à l'assaut de la
présidence de la haute normandie propose
des filières par exemple pour les deux
centrales nucléaires via les 10'' ya les
faisais moi je suis à faisons qu il faut
une formation particulière cette
formation il ya une école qui la donne
où est elle elle est dans l'est de la
route si vous allez dans cette école
vous êtes sûr
après de pouvoir être embauchés sur
place pourquoi est-ce que nous alors que
nous avons des centrales nucléaires nous
ne serions pas capables de former sur
place des jeunes qui après serait
certain de trouver des emplois arrivé à
rapprocher
l'information est long ça c'est votre
mère
cette écoute des besoins de la région et
des soucis des élus locaux représentent
bien le style fabius en haute normandie
depuis son arrivée ses adversaires
disent parachutage dans le conseil
municipal de grand quevilly n'a cessé de
tisser un réseau où michael sheen
d'amitié politique se raison lui permet
de contrôler le sivom de l'agglomération
rouennaise et de compter sept sur les
dix députés socialistes pour ses amis
reste pour lui à conquérir la forteresse
rpr udf 6 au conseil régional et de
tenter d'affaiblir jean lecanu et pour
les sièges renouvelables au conseil
général la situation politique nationale
est empoisonné pour le ps et ne favorise
pas l'offensive fabius sa campagne
pratiquement uniquement orientée sur la
ville normande se veut un puissant
antidote